yeah hello welcome to this broadcast on
Monday show with one hour of chess
explained I hope a little bit at least
um yeah it would be difficult to top
last week's show when I was going 7 to 0
very nice against the five middle pool
which is very difficult to do so I'll
see what I can do today welcome all of
you in the chat unfortunately I didn't
manage to fix the issue of the somewhat
bad background due to the light to the
lighting didn't have the time today to
fix it but I should I will do that right
after the show is probably the way to go
I need to get better lighting in there
but a light gain started Bob sauce LED
lights a good okay I've got black in the
first game I'm playing B C and V whoever
that is yeah let's go for the reversed
wrong free which is a good weapon if
people don't play it well okay I think
I'm happy to take and cancel so oh
there's a request phone rang at tang mmm
do I have to maybe I will
it's borderline okay there's a question
by Mark David Buchholz I think playing
the French defense against efore I was
at rusev before 20 years say a way I can
branch out and still use some of the
theory I know it's a bit tricky with the
French I think the French defense
positions are very um yeah a very unique
in a way and not really I don't think
there is much
yeah that's not the typical opening that
you could play instead where things are
kind of similar you can argue that maybe
the count come defense is some is
somewhat similar as it is a LightSquared
defense but still I feel that it's still
a big big difference
okay um Queen d2 hmm I think I probably
have to spend a move
at one point here okay so what is the
point
Bishop c6 is the simple point so I
probably have to do this okay um well I
think now I will go-ahead for I mean no
matter if it's good or not this is in
the spirit of the position okay Bishop
f6 okay I'll take with the rook yeah
also you know what to all of the
regulars in the chat someone says stream
down I hope it's not the case
91 so it seems he wants to get the
knight to f3 hmm yeah
understandable yeah I got a message that
there were some frames dropped I hope
this is not a huge issue ongoing issue
okay Bishop h3 this is dangerous
it really is really wow this I didn't
expect okay I think look f8 looks normal
it's going to get made
yeah I'm very happy with my my new place
after my move everything is working fine
and what is he doing here come on you
cannot be serious
this is just one check right so I'll
take this and that's it
where's where's the defense here
Luke c8 is just a check I was thinking I
would have three events maybe I have
something quicker even okay three looks
good though no it is a dangerous attack
the reversed grown Prius not so bad
okay this was the point I mean I'm still
a piece up but I wonder and I think I'll
just I just take and now how to do it
getting the night over is probably right
and if he takes the screen g5 the night
comes to f4 this is probably difficult
to defend
okay Night Moves
there is the rook check
check okay I have to reconsider a little
bit Jim rugby 795 however should be good
the night coming to age for many white
resigns yeah I think I have to place the
chat differently so that I'm not
constantly looking on the left-hand side
okay I won the first game that's good
so at least I have got some some chance
to to get to the same scores last week
even though this is difficult 7 0 s is
very tough to do I've got a request for
the French defense my French defense ko
is kind of kind of not so great but I
could try if I'm getting I mean well
I'll see what my opponents ratings on if
I'm getting someone who's not like
strontium ok yeah I'll go I go for the
French and I can also play the rang
attack if the opponent is not like 2,600
GM ok that line with Bishop III hmm yeah
Queen b6 is normal but it's probably
just developing isn't bad either
the Scandinavian no I'm not sure
not that the Scandinavian is a bad
opening but this is just not my kind of
position I never know what I should do
in those positions ok Bishop to d3
[Music]
yeah I wonder how to play that 9f5
I'm kind of I'm fear that he takes it
and I'm not sure that I like to like
that idea it's not the end of the world
but not so happy with it oh he takes
with the bishop oh I'm happy with that
not because of the bishop pair but
because of trading some stuff okay I
think I'll go him and now if I go Queen
b6 maybe Queen b6 attacking the pawn and
I will definitely take it if he allows
me to do it I don't think the
Scandinavian is a bad opening really not
but it's just not my kind of position
[Music]
okay so I'm happy to provoke some stuff
b3 is not a move that white is white is
happy to play oh so he actually wants to
give me two bishops against two knights
Vega 94
hmm yeah I think I will do it
[Music]
sufficient to seven and castles I guess
fy5 huh
that might be an option for him doesn't
seem doesn't seem to be his idea what is
that flag by the way Ethiopia
okay I'm interesting that's not a flag I
am I knew yeah so I've got the two
bishops against them two knights ob3 wow
that is surprising move that he allows
Bishop before Bishop III stuff unless
I'm overlooking something which is very
very much possible
[Music]
[Music]
okay it should be before I don't quite
know even goes back on what I see right
now
I will see what he does
there's a question that's no real
question there's a someone is quoting
parts of the game that he played but I
don't really get the question at the
moment um we should be five I guess I
look at three though maybe
okay go Queen a5 yeah Victoire ik skull
I don't really see a question I
understand your moves that you that you
mentioned but I'm not sure if you have
enough compensation they have then it's
your question it looks a little bit
fishy to me yeah in this position the
danger is that he might get some kind of
@ echoing him rook f3 but I have Bishop
you aid
yeah I've got more time on the clock
which is nice
rare occurrence yeah what is he going
for look g3 I mean I will take on c3
probably or maybe he draws by some kind
of Perpetual rookie g3 I will probably
play g6 um you know that's a question
how to pronounce my last name it's Z
Lackey there's no nothing special about
it at least for for German speaking okay
Luke g3
yeah it's dangerous without a question
if I go g6 if I take one c3 if we look
at this first you'll play rock g7 takes
and this is going to be a perpetual I
think there's odd no where's the
perpetual Queen h6g six rook h3 this is
probably okay then okay you have to be
practical here and just to cover this
[Music]
okay so p5 before then
who cares read sh6 now yes our time he
cannot move any of his pieces them this
is the problem yes so I can take the
three now before I sought alternative
yeah this is probably better just attack
this this night it doesn't have a good
square to go yeah
[Music]
Lukas detect then they have Queen c2
coming which is also I'm threatening
Queen e2 but I'm also defending yeah
here isn't look isn't 22 winning now I
should win Farouk c1 yeah it's a winning
counter tonight for fits on time
and yeah Victoire ik after this Bishop
d6 move I think probably just Bishop g3
but I don't want to go into any details
there because people probably don't
don't follow what what what do what you
ask this is a bit difficult now I guess
yeah of course I've got two wins and
that's good so it's not like I'm
struggling to get a winning one single
win at the first place I'll go one
before now next game if I have a let's
say not super strong grandmaster takes a
while to get the game going
game started Jerome I have a good score
against Jerome so maybe this is this is
not so terrible
okay he doesn't play five which is good
news yeah I think this kind of stuff is
actually quite okay for white I think a
white can be reasonably happy with the
opening
I don't know B should be too long I
think I'll go Bishop e2 I'm not sure
about my D pawn yet
d3 can be interesting interesting okay I
think I'll take
[Music]
okay what about this okay a creamy three
it takes on b5 this is a bit annoying
actually
okay I go default it's it looks a bit
strange but I my ideas to go in 45 if
possible not huh
interesting move okay I think I'll just
develop him I want to keep that pawn on
d5 because it is restricting black quite
quite well yeah it seems the stream is a
little bit unsteady I don't really I
don't know why actually I never changed
anything here in the setup and my
connection is really quick we'll see
what happens
yeah Knights you form a text text the b6
pawn
[Music]
and I can't they I've got a little bit
more pieces in play okay 96 not that
great
[Music]
whenever 65 can you take you cannot
easily take that with the piece I think
no it doesn't take with the piece so I
can actually take on f6 if I like and
Queen cannot take maybe 95 I'm not sure
if I really gets I'm really having
something substantial here but maybe
it's a little bit easier for me to play
if I get an F 3 at you for my position
is really nice but that's not so easy to
do 93 years maybe an idea
okay I go to be three hunky lights a
score above play d4 Knight f6 c4 g 6h
for today and lost after 25 hours
probably
deservedly so H floor looks that looks
weird
maybe not weird enough that you should
be worse or much worse but it's a bit of
a strange move ok 3 g5 I'm not sure that
f4 is a move that I like to play it wins
a temper which is cool I think
well I cannot sacrifice or something
like that right can a knight takes a 4
Wow ok so probably I hope I'm not
overlooking stuff him
you know I just go back I just go back
just go back keep everything safe and
sound
I still have night a five I would see
one I'm not getting checkmated now okay
how to do this hey that's really that
difficult difficult position
thinking of Bishop f3 and 94 maybe
somewhat down on the clock Hanson's can
be tricky there was a question thoughts
on the candidates
yeah I'm looking looking forward to that
tournament enormous leap it is yeah
basically just around the corner
starting in just a couple of days night
back to six I would like to get in that
f3 and you for maybe I get to the other
zone it weakens the dark squares though
okay we'll see yeah I'm looking for that
looking forward to the tournament a lot
I think they have big questions already
in former streams about who have thought
who I'm thinking is the favorite and I
don't think there is a clear favorite
okay maybe I can get the 96 Queen g5
that's an annoying move 9625 as possible
time Arnage 23 now that doesn't look so
great actually
it's got 95 but I didn't see an
alternative here not so nice not so nice
oh okay - I shoot damn it that's not
good that's not good what a bad game ah
I had a good position actually it wasn't
so bad really not I think I actually had
a big advantage but now I've screwed it
up
[Music]
[Music]
maybe he still has some practical
problems well probably Jack it is rather
easy to win especially considering that
I have no time that's too bad
what a shame that was a really good
position I would also use on time
unfortunately okay that was bad it was
really bad reasons
[Music]
the odds to win interesting bookmaker
gives four point five to one for koala
at aronia and five from Nakamura five
for Giri eight for kayaking nine for
nine nine four two polyp hmm that seems
kind of okay
I think spirit of 14 no I don't think so
I think Sunnah has about the same
chances as to par love has or or or
Anand has maybe but it is about the same
a lot depends on the first two or three
rounds getting a quick winnin is super
important and I had a very good position
here
I should have shouldn't have lost the
game I kind of lost track around here
White's position is pretty good actually
maybe that idea was wrong I don't know
23 no no Queen III was excellent game
start anyway new game against geheime
put its I the secret police what do they
do
okay I'm night f3 let's play something
unconventional with b6 okay that's not
so unconventional we can take care of it
and now maybe Knight f6 interesting
interesting with with d5 here so maybe 6
or B 5 is also move but maybe Queen b3
then I think I go 86
[Music]
[Music]
okay so 30 kids here see five no that's
the most lip right white resign oh it
was very lucky yeah he just Mouse
slipped and resigned I can just take the
pawn knock him I would've been in a good
game and against the Grandmaster maybe
no we don't know who that is he doesn't
have a name in them it's a bit of a
shame okay
keys start for a new game against
shootin it's my move
I'm sorry I totally totally forgot to
move I have a really bad score against
this person one out of six
this is miserable and he plays the Kings
Indian why do I have a bad score against
him I don't get it
usually I should have a good score if
they play the Kings in here so we'll see
what happens
96 okay
[Music]
[Music]
and there's the question if someone
watched the MMA fight some someone
against someone I don't even know what
the MMA is I'm sorry guys I I guess
that's probably some kind of ultimate
fighting or something like that but I
really have no idea and I don't watch
any of that okay so maybe a groupie one
but should be three
[Music]
Jim I can't go night p5 it's not a big
deal or 984 therefore that's not before
down and I think I go there I know I
don't think I'm going to produce any of
its own videos on Skyrim that that game
is also quite dated
I don't think there's much interest I
think
[Music]
yeah I think in the candidates
tournament
I mean someone said that well Vichy had
a bad result in Gibraltar with two
stitches true but it doesn't really mean
anything for that event I mean he won
the candidates two years ago and he won
that rather convincingly and he had
rotten results all the way up to that
event I mean really bad results so I
think that you cannot really read
anything into into that or I can draw
any conclusions there well played
probably grb-2 is hanging and I don't
have a good way to cover it
rugby one looks pretty bad but well I
cannot give him the pawn it's just what
it is I cannot give it give me with a
pawn okay um what do I do here b3 looks
bad
[Music]
gee three or four is very loose
I cannot go to have three unfortunately
hmm yeah it's really not great
[Music]
this is hanging now but I mean hanging
is wrong with it's kind of under attack
I have to play that I guess at some
point to to make my route could be one
mobile
[Music]
[Music]
what is coming up here
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's very uncomfortable very
uncomfortable yeah I know it weakens the
dark squares and gives the a foul but I
cannot play without the rukon be
wonderful game really cannot ok ok I was
I wasn't sure yet 26 is also very valid
move or be seven time morning eight
seven six is not enough doesn't quite
work doesn't quite work Chang
and there seem to be some issues with
the stream usually refreshing helps
rook a 70 cent had some Queen f6
[Music]
I know yes rookie one check shoot that
chicken Bishop e5 all of a sudden nah
that was bad
okay white reason this is why I have a
bed Scoy and soon probably just you just
tricked me here did this is this is
probably okay for wide right and how is
it okay hmm I was thought I thought that
should be it should be okay yeah and
check but maybe you can really defend
okay seven assists not so great because
of that tough to say okay let's go for a
knee game started and not analyze too
much chess coach for you okay let's see
I've never played this guy let's let's
play the London system and yeah I don't
really believe in e4 here so to e3 yeah
I know the London is not the most
exciting opening but after the last game
I need some kind of need to relax a
little bit really
I don't think that this works but and
I'm not totally sure of course
[Music]
[Music]
okay I can take on c4 okay man let's do
it be sure
I wonder if Bishop e3 is an idea here or
Wow okay I'll go back but should be
three no a6 assessments okay well yeah I
can go back probably very tough Oh Queen
b6 no and I have no idea 595 wasn't why
didn't he do that
95 still irritates me
I think I probably have to cover that
would be one night
just have to make sure that the Queen
stays strapped yeah I might play match
against John Bartholomew again if he is
up to it last time it was a pretty even
affair we had two equal scorers and
blitz but he beat me pretty convincingly
in the bullet in the bullet section okay
so what now I have the chickie and then
take on e5 maybe check okay so very
tricky c4
[Music]
I also have 93 here right 93 so queen
rupee one something like that let's see
check oh that I didn't take into account
oh I'm not I'm not I'm not material up
here that's surprising I didn't see that
one coming
okay just yes didn't see that I thought
I'm just material of but I'm not
[Music]
[Music]
I'll take this rock I'll take it that
was very generous black resigns okay so
why was a win very tough game up there
was there were chances for sure for
black there's some guy in that shed
don't freak I know this guy he's uh he
has posted some comments on my videos
and usually it's just just bashing
players that are like ten times better
than years and he currently says that
John Bartholomew is a weak tactician
which is cool possibly will simply beat
you probably with his hands only so we
should turn just be a yeah whatever
sitting there with your computer running
is always busy okay well getting this
out of from getting this some said I put
up this this opening which is not very
exciting unfortunately okay really not
okay so there's a question now with his
hands only this is not a German
expression the German expression is
actually unsuitable for this kind of
broadcast um so there's a question yeah
I recommend to play the Queens gambit
declined article why it's a good line of
course it's very very solid defense but
still something that can be played with
ambition so it's not like totally boring
if you play some stuff like the Laska
defense let's say it is really boring
but tatacoa is kind of interesting
[Music]
okay interesting move I can take with
the both pieces actually I think I'll go
for the night for activity
yeah that's okay
yeah I think I'm reasonably happy
considering that I didn't really pay so
much attention here as I was busy
handling this guy in the chat okay yeah
that looks kind of okay I just wondered
maybe hmm
[Music]
interesting so hook c4i move I mean if
you take I don't really see the point to
be honest I don't see a big point here
[Music]
let's see four looks kind of passive but
anyway might be to for draw well that
looks entirely wrong um so what you do
and 94 9f 94 95 this kind of thing is
it's possible I think I'll cover this I
just cover defy for the moment okay um
f6 is not possible unfortunately I try
to put more pressure down
[Music]
nice age six he probably known the
thought night age forward I can take him
I can't take oh I didn't see that move
that's bad I didn't see that one coming
it's uncomfortable
okay this is not possible King h8 is not
working what am I doing here and I
divorce also around the corner
I don't like it
but I didn't see a move now didn't see
you move
[Music]
I think he can take just take it twice
I'll take a five and I was just hoping
that the spin is not that not just not
fatal it might be fatal but I thought
this is rookie five okay it's God rupee
five this is a bad problem time morning
yeah okay so mmm something else
something else something else something
else
f-for Quincy five which would save it
but I have no way to go for that my dad
it's not working
[Music]
that probably won't work and I have no
time no it doesn't work okay check yeah
that's when a queen ev6 picks up the
roof okay yeah nicely nicely played
nicely played I mean he blundered the
b-pawn but he got really some strong
compensation him I mean here I'm better
but it's it's not it's not easy to do at
least I couldn't I couldn't do it maybe
this is really already wrong this that's
very bad it's very very uncomfortable in
blitz chess really is okay so what do we
have what does a time to us five minutes
to 11 my end so still time for one or
two games started playing an arc
Grandmaster are with that Wow shall I
call who is that I said someone from
India to someone know that Korra I don't
know him so the names oh yeah okay so
what do i do yeah I think I go see Fife
right this is my line yeah Weston M
Weston is a strong player I have a +
Corbett's always very tough
someone asked me about my my new home
yeah as I said I'm very happy everything
is working nicely and I like it a lot
everything's good so see fiber sayings I
probably have ulti recovery that's a
very weird opening isn't why it's
struggling here I'm torn up or not I'm
pulling up right and I don't really see
anything that white has
okay what is the point what is the point
mr. arc de for already is close to
working but I think I'll just go to aim
for him for Lucca pb2 coming
[Music]
yeah I can also check which is not bad
the Kashuk looks that looks fine bishop
d1 cannot be a very happy move for wine
so maybe d4 and c3 that looks pretty
rotten yeah
no it'd be too and resins or what is the
plan
Bishop a6 is also good white it was a
terrible opening really and white he did
something wrong there a3 is kind of
strange already okay so quick win
against this Grandmaster I think I'll up
go for one more
[Music]
I'm not quite sure how many games I have
played has said that they ate the eighth
game maybe I don't know let me have a
look he said the eighth game oh no I
already have played 8 games and this is
the ninth game that's it's rare and I've
got a decent score I've got like three
plus five minus three so game starting
OH Cillian I shouldn't have played
another game I always struggle against
them I mean let's say it's a it's a it's
an open fight a really good player here
from Italy so I'll go for boring game
but at least I I know stuff him
hmm
this has a slightly shady reputation
actually at 95 95 I think I'm not
completely shown okay that looks like a
nice position I think and I'm somewhat
oh it just gives me that that's
surprising I think he did something
similar in a game against me just
recently and in that game also was
surprised so he tries to occupy you for
him
I don't want 94m capturing this is this
is looking very lame so maybe this h5
it's not a move I took into account
really Roxas 7s the idea
[Music]
hmmm looks good yeah but it doesn't seem
like I have a clear way forward for this
I don't really know he defends he
defends nicely
yeah that movies community 5 looks a
little bit annoying it's not clear that
it actually threatens something Bishop
takes g6 on a very good day but it's
probably not one of those days you know
26 and very this one your rooks is 70
always had Group D so I think that just
traded stuff I might be wrong but I
think it just traded stuff
[Music]
[Music]
okay so it looks a little bit a little
bit uncomfortable but how do i how do I
actually get something here
Bishop c6 doesn't really need too much
[Music]
you can barely move really
but still don't see anything
maybe maybe G for King F 24 but she
cannot take because of rook H 1 that
could be an interesting tribe I can take
it right
but Jacobs assassin some f6 or what I
don't don't get it
f6 don't tell me yes root g8 f6
that's unbelievable
[Music]
okay I think you think you really had
this move which is crazy absolutely
crazy but I hope this works
[Music]
maybe saves with Knight h6 which looks
completely bonkers time morning the look
is hanging actually
[Music]
Hey look g8 whose post doing this stuff
Luke g8 f6 unbelievable that this was
saving at least I think it's saved
absolutely crazy and how it's playing
stuff like that our GeForce bad move
[Music]
all hard to believe it's still not so
easy if he moves his rooks to the second
or so I have Bishop d7 and the knight
has no squares it's still not easy my
ideas rook dg8 and rook h5 checkmate
maybe this is something that I can try
[Music]
check yeah you survived it
you really survived this Wow you know
this guy always has been a difficult
opponent for me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah by now we will be not time no
matter what
[Music]
now you wouldn't know
ah come on I cannot believe this stuff
that that here Luke g8 is failing due to
f6 can you believe that it fails due to
f6 unbelievable
okay winning is route d3 I mean it's
clear that white should win this but I
didn't see it
I simply didn't see it this seems to
somehow hold Queen d6 wins though and
this was winning immediately future
Queen age five okay okay that was a
there was stuff that was really tough um
okay there was a really hard game okay I
think this stream is over
I have played I played what was that
nine games that's kind of kind of
unusual I think I had a slide plus score
with those games even though I lost some
rating okay I hope you enjoyed the
stream it was um it was very invent for
games thanks for watching guys I'll be
back next week bye bye